a phenomenon is threatening marine life
in the Gulf of Mexico the largest dead
zone ever recorded in the US has
appeared at the mouth of the Mississippi
River it is primarily caused by
fertilizer and sewage that wash off
farmland in the rivers watershed now
this runoff eventually makes its way to
the sea where it feeds algae blooms and
bacteria that suck all the oxygen out of
the water scientists announced this
month the dead zone measures nearly nine
thousand square miles you think about
that for a second it's the same area as
the state of New Jersey
Jeff Gore is in Dulac Louisiana with how
this dead zone is impacting one of the
largest seafood industries in the
country Jeff good morning Gail good
morning to you on usually heavy rains in
the Midwest this year resulted in more
water in the Mississippi and then more
water here in the Gulf and that resulted
in that biggest dead zone in history in
the US and that is difficult news for
the fishermen who provide 40 percent of
this nation's seafood
underwater video we recorded yesterday
afternoon shows the transition from life
to death as green fades to black it
becomes so dark divers need flashlights
to find their way around down here there
is almost no oxygen in the water and
this voice stretches over an enormous
portion of the goal this is the largest
one we've ever measured and the second
largest human caused dead zone
Nancy Rabalais is the nation's foremost
expert on dead zones
she's been measuring oxygen levels in
the Gulf since 1985 it's a feature
that's large it's not getting smaller
and attempts to manage the nutrients
nitrogen or
the river are not having an effect on
reduce
deadzones happen when agricultural
runoff sends nitrogen-rich fertilizer
downstream into the sea the fertilizer
feeds harmful amounts of algae at the
surface that eventually die and sink to
the bottom
bacteria feast on the dead algae
removing oxygen from the water and fish
crabs and shrimp are forced to leave or
suffocate and die the solution lies up
upstream in the watershed with better
agricultural management practices a
switch to crops that have deeper roots
and
fertilizer and are still just as
profitable as corn the water we watch
the measure yesterday has less than half
the oxygen needed to support basic fish
life it's almost like a different planet
it's all around you from 30 to 60 feet
we won't see any pitch nothing these
species of shrimp are not there like
they used to be Oh Neil John Stephen has
been fishing these waters more than 40
years from a fishing perspective you're
talking about smaller shrimp or or no
shrimp at all correct a study led by
Duke University published this year
found that dead zones in the Gulf do
slow shrimp growth resulting in higher
prices for larger shrimp do you see this
issue getting better anytime soon I wish
it would I really do wish it were the
EPA has set up a task force to look at
dead zones they are hoping to reduce
nutrient rich runoff by 20% by 2025
Nora Jeff thank you for that reporting
really interesting to think about that
they know we did a good job